[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing dumbledore
voldemort frank bryce and the goblet of
fire
more specifically we're going to be
discussing dumbledore's
seemingly all-knowing knowledge of all
occurrences
that take place in the wizarding world
specifically the death
of muggle frank bryce frank bryce was a
muggle who came from
and lived in the village of little
hangleton england
the same place where voldemort's family
was from
as a young man bryce served in world war
ii
and when he returned home to little
hangleton he ended
up becoming a gardener for the riddle
family unfortunately for bryce
when a young tom riddle finally returned
home to kill his father
and grandparents successfully i might
add
the only person left at the scene of the
crime was frank
for this reason he was the primary
suspect for the riddle's murder
a crime that he obviously did not commit
though bryce was a primary suspect in
the real murders and though he was
initially arrested
there also wasn't sufficient evidence
that he had
done it which meant that he was able to
avoid jail time
however the townspeople of little
hangleton treated him like an outcast
from that point onward unable to believe
that anyone else could have killed
the riddles as far as i'm concerned he
killed them
and i don't care what the police say and
if he had any decency
he'd leave here dot a little hangleton
resident
after bryce was released from the police
station he returned to the riddle family
grounds
where he lived a solitary disconnected
life in a small cottage
fortunately bryce was kept on as gardner
by the house's succession of unnamed
owners
bryce lived on the riddle grounds for
many years however
shortly before his 77th birthday bryce
was murdered by lord voldemort
after nagini informed voldemort that
bryce had overheard them discussing
their plans
to kill harry potter he was screaming so
loudly
that he never heard the words the thing
in the chair spoke as it raised a wand
there was a flash of green light a
rushing sound and frank bryce crumbled
he was dead before he hit the floor
however bryce didn't go out without
giving riddle the young whippersnapper
some attitude is that right lord is it
well i don't think much of your manners
my lord
turn around and face me like a man why
don't you what's particularly
interesting about bryce's death
however is that dumbledore seem to
somehow know about
it chapter 23 of the half-blood prince
mentions this
after an interval of some years from
voldemort's first death
however he used nagini to kill an old
muggle man
and it might then have occurred to him
to turn her into his last horcrux
so my question is how how could
dumbledore have possibly known about the
death of an old muggle man
in a little town the answer to this
question actually lies in the books
however it was mentioned much earlier on
in the goblet of fire
dumbledore's side again and he looked
older and warier than ever
the years of voldemorts are sent to
power he said were marked with
disappearances
bertha jorkins has vanished without
trace in the place where voldemort was
certainly known
to be last mr crouch too has disappeared
within these very grounds
and there was a third disappearance one
which the ministry
i regret to say does not consider of any
importance
for it concerns a muggle his name was
frank bryce
he lived in the village where
voldemort's father grew up and he has
not been seen
since last august you see i read the
mughal newspapers
unlike most of my ministry friends
dumbledore looked very seriously at
harry
these disappearances seem to me to be
linked the ministry disagrees
as you may have heard while waiting
outside of my office
so as you can see the answer to
dumbledore's knowledge of bryce's death
isn't anything sinister like a lot of
you probably expected
you know who you are the ones who are
convinced that dumbledore is evil
he simply read the newspaper and that's
it for this video
leave your video suggestions down below
until next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you